[Music]
when we got the opportunity to work on
the next game of the series we sat down
with the rest of the Court team and husk
ourselves as fun what kind of Assassin's
Creed game we'd most want to play many
of us felt the desire to revisit some of
the old imagery narrative theme and
gameplays that made us fall in love with
the series after 15 years of Journeys
across the ages from the Third Crusade
with Altair to the Viking expansions
with Ivor we wanted to go back closely
to Where it All Began and pay homage to
the beginnings of Assassin's Creed
we started to explore the idea of
introducing a new playable hero Bassin
and creating an experience that is a
love letter to the origins of the
franchise coming a fetch story with
rhythm mechanics to bring the feel of
the early games into the modern day we
are going back to the Middle East but
this time in 9th century Baghdad 300
years before the time of Altair we are
telling the story of Basim and we became
a master assassin
we look at the first AC games and
started to wonder what exactly defined
the Assassin experience to us and from
there we put all our efforts into
bringing our Tech and the Assassin
fantasy
[Music]
is a key pillar to the experience with
Baghdad as your playground we are
bringing the action back to Urban
environment for parkour we look to our
previous games for inspiration and just
to put the emphasis on comfort and
fluidity in Mirage Parker is easy to
learn and to master our approach is
closer to the SEO games where it's all
about keeping the flow and the momentum
going with the design centered around
verticality many elements from past
games are making a return we have the
current swing the ability to Vault over
objects elevators to quickly reach high
ground but also new ingredients such as
the pole vault allowing you to cross
large gaps between two rooftops of
course Basim is faster and more agile
than ever was and to give that feeling
we worked our animations to reinforce
the sense of speed When jumping vaulting
and free roaming streets are narrower
denser and packed with obstacles to
navigate by choosing the right pass
through the environment you can move
from street level to the rooftops in a
blink of an eye a useful skill for any
assassin
[Music]
another car focus of Mirage tells we
want players to work in the shadows plan
their next move strike and then vanish
there are more ways to assassinate with
new Killing animations some leveraging a
stealthy approach others delivering a
violent killing blow we also have direct
Throwbacks to the first games with moves
like the bench assassination that you
might recognize from a C2 or the Kill
from the rooftop gardens an old favorite
we want to encourage you to be sneaky
bassim has been trained to fight by the
hidden ones but for him combat is a last
resort and his main approach is to hunt
and strike while remaining unnoticed we
also reworked our enemy AI to improve
detection and Vanishing Loops making our
behaviors more responsive and readable
new enemy archetypes will also increase
the stakes The Marksman can shoot your
ego and prevent you from using it the
Spearman pokes through Haystacks and own
Bearer can call for reinforcements
that's where your assassin skills come
in handy
during his training in alamut
back read from his mentor Roshan and his
fellow hidden ones we get to see him
learn the tenets and philosophies that
will guide him through his missions like
hiding in plain sight social stealth is
making a return we are bringing back the
systemic blending with larger crowds
that all you to move undetected through
the business location but you cannot
survives more factions with specific
tokens in order to control AI groups and
make your way through guarded areas
as a NASA senior Court mission is to
track down and eliminate the order of
the Ancients and feedback that of their
influence in our game the hidden ones
have established a network of bureaus
across the city to keep an eye on the
order the bureaus in Mirage act as
gameplay Ebbs from which you can take on
site contracts with various objectives
from rescue missions to assassinations
and LG Indian ones in their Fight For
Freedom we want you to feel truly
immersed in the life of a hidden one
investigating your Target's identities
tracking their movements and sharing
information with your lives then when
the time is right you can strike from
the Shadows we've crafted a new
investigation board which replaces our
most recent Quest log in Mirage and with
our Black Box missions we give you the
freedom to approach key assassination
missions however you see things we know
are excited our community is we also
have a nice surprise for our long timers
we implemented the nostalgic visual
filter as an option for those who wish
to explore the game with a desaturated
blue gray color palette from the very
first AC game
this is a project played by a team of
passionate people who have their very
own vision of the Assassin experience in
mind there is much to come and we can't
wait to unveil more about bassim's
Journey
[Music]
[Applause]